[Music]
so I am done back there I'm the Member
of Parliament for Brent central and I'm
the shadow Secretary of State for women
and equalities so I do obviously my my
role is about equality and as I've been
working over the last few years and I
mean wondering why where we've got kind
of targets in regards to women
inequality etc and why progress has been
slow and it got me thinking about and it
was a year ago this week I went to
America and I was interviewed by Shonda
Rhimes people know Shonda Rhimes scandal
Grey's Anatomy I love Grace and I watch
Grey's Anatomy
I've grace great writing anyway so
skerin tall Grey's Anatomy
so Shonda Rhimes end and I talked about
the career ladder so I started to
thinking about climbing this career
ladder and why so few women are at the
top often and then I thought well the
problem is the actual ladder so when we
talk about this career ladder and the
construct the contract of a career
ladder it's designed for one person to
get to the top so often in an
organization when we talk about
diversity is almost like a tick box
they'll be like well we've got a woman
we've got a black person we've got an
LGBT plan we're done tick we're done
yeah and sometimes when that person's
got to the top they've kicked the ladder
away because they think it's better that
there's only one because they're safer
when actually what you need is more
around the table and we do know that
companies that have diversity at the top
on average earn fifth make 15% more than
companies that don't have diversity at
the top so diversity pays so before we
used to talk about hearts and minds the
right thing to do we've got legislation
about the Equality Act but I
we're making progress by talking about
the bottom line you want to make money
you need to have more diversity at the
top so I started thinking about this
career ladder and I said we need to what
we haven't done is lay foundations for
more people to get to the top because at
every let me know if I if I lose you at
any stage just put your hand up and let
me know if I've lost it and say so I
talked to I talked to people about their
journey and some people fight really
hard at each rung of this ladder to try
and get to the top they put in extra
hours they work hard and somehow they
don't progress some people than if
you've heard the time accidental
managers make it to the top and people
think how the hell did that person get
there do you mean I can do that job
better than there how how did they make
it there you know what is it why did
they make it to the top you know and
they've not had to worry about each rung
of this ladder and some people
especially women don't Trump time don't
even attempt to climb the ladder
sometimes they have to climb down if
they're having children family if
they've got caring responsibility do all
of this so the accidental managers by
the way they get there in a certain way
and I'm going to come to that and so I
think what we have to do is lay
foundations for an escalator so that you
don't have to worry about each rung of
the ladder about pleasing different
people to get further and further up if
that's where you want to go it should be
that we have a system that's clear and
transparent so that's why I'll give you
an example the gender pay gap so we know
the gender pay gap women an average and
18 percent less than men so what we're
saying is as a labor party what we want
organizations and companies to do is to
make sure that they have a transparent
system where everybody can see the pay
structure so you know how much you're
being paid and so the organizations have
to have clear action plans to how they
go into work to close that pay gap so
once you've got clear action plans it
means that everybody has more of a fair
a chance to rise up that's how we're
laying the foundations
an escalator that's where we're
dismantling the structural inequality
barriers okay you still with me so so
for instance when you want to escalator
right in there it's very easy to
understand the rules quite quite clearly
right if you're standing on the wrong
side of an escalator somebody's gonna
tell you about it right so in Singapore
for instance you stand on the left you
know in the UK we stand on the right so
when I went to Singapore I was standing
on the right and people still told me to
move to the left to the left to the left
I don't mind that so um so so you see
you soon understand the rule was because
it's transparent cuz it's easy to see
people are standing on one side and
people walking up the next side you soon
get the hang of it because moods start
pushing Parsi so that's what
accountability that's what action plans
will do in organisations they will make
it more transparent so people will be
able to get to the top much more quickly
now you know we talked I mentioned
accidental managers I'm sure some of you
met some anybody met an accidental
manager anybody has an accidental
manager okay so they got there often
not always I am generalizing here in
this often by privilege often by who
they know this is very much real in
politics who they know who they're
friends with and who they gave them the
access code to the lifts so they do not
have to even worry about being on an
escalator they went straight to the lift
pressed a button and they're at the top
and so what I'm saying is if we want to
change the social structural barriers in
society to make it more equal we have to
lay foundations for transparency so
people can rise to the top
I used to be you know large law firm I
don't really understand how and I'm not
opposed to transparency on the earnings
don't really understand how transparency
on earnings translates to enhanced
opportunity because often what happens
is people get paid get paid people get
paid different rates for doing the same
job right so even the BBC this week
there's a woman that decided that she
wasn't going to take the job because it
was twelve thousand pounds less than a
man who starting the job at the same
time doing the same job so if you have
transparency then organizations have to
think very carefully about who they
promote how much they get paid etc so
they can no longer pay somebody a lot of
money for not doing a job because often
you'll find that somebody's doing the
job of some videos who's being paid for
the job that they're doing anybody in
that position yeah you find yourself
doing the job and somebody else is
taking credit for it and also getting
paid for it so once things become
transparent you can measure it you can
identify it and then where necessary you
can work to change it so once
organizations stopped sweeping things
under the carpet then things will start
to become more equal my impression is
that we've headed in the opposite
direction to the one that you're talking
about and we're starting from a lower
base I'm particularly concerned about
how technology makes things less
transparent so I'm thinking for example
just the strap line for LinkedIn is it's
not what you know it's who you know I
mean that that is that is true in all
professions in a way but in regards to
technology actually it's what you know
if you're able to do the job so often
you do find in the tech sector it is
what you it is what you know but so if
you know how to program really well for
instance you can program if you can
program you can program and you often
get you know get paid the right rate for
the job so it's one of those industries
where the the pay disparity isn't as
Stark often
but I don't think technology
I don't think technology will stops
people from being more transparent or
from making sure that people have fate
paid fairly or paid a great rate for the
role is that what you meant when you
dimension technology the main concern is
technology doesn't help transparency
because it could more can be hidden yeah
whether it's Huawei lot could be hidden
but but no not really
I don't think so I wouldn't say I
totally agree with that but but but the
point is transparency is key
we've got to stop organisations from
hiding things or paying people through
the back door creating bonuses whether
you know doesn't really exist just so
they can pay somebody more money because
of who they know for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you